hello recently I've been receiving quite
a few questions on my American accent so
I just decided to make a video on it
there's a video that I made three years
ago we're explaining how I learn
American English but I would like to
explain it further in more details I saw
a couple of threads on the internet
where people said suggest that I have an
American mother or that I lived in the
United States when I was a little kid I
am obviously flattered by these
suggestions because maybe means that I
speak American English decently but the
point is that it prompted me to tell
tell you my personal story now I am I
was born and raised in Rome in a 100%
monolingual family so my mother and my
father they speak Italian my father also
speaks also knows English but it's
scientific English or he writes very
well in English but it's as far as
speaking as concerned that's not the
best that's net that's not the best of a
scope of his skills um now as every
other ten-year-old Italian kid I started
England started to learn English at
school and the Italian school system is
not as bad as they depicted but the
problem is it's it's quite inefficient
as far as language learning is concerned
plus my teacher was from Sardinia and
she had a very thick sword in Ian's
accent when she spoke English so at the
beginning I picked up when I picked up
was kind of mixed between Sardinian and
English and I don't know it was
something weird and I do remember that
at the end of the first year a couple
years later I still pronounced enough
like you know that's what I my American
my American teacher was shocked and
talking about my American teacher my
mother decided that it was about
to have to for me to learn English
properly so we had a private tutor she
is great she is a great girl from
Chicago to say it haven't seen her in a
long time actually because she came back
to the United States but I still
treasure her lessons and were so good
and they were incredibly motivating and
I think that she did what a teacher
should do that is to guide the learner
and not to lecture him whenever he makes
a mistake to encourage him and to give
him material and that's what she did she
gave me so much motivation and I do
remember that she recorded for example
two recording movies and for me in
English and I avidly watched them all
the time and it was she did a wonderful
job and I wrote for example essays for
her and I wrote articles that she
corrected all the time and but what I
did she she gave me you know motivation
but um Lange just cannot be taught they
can only learn and what he did is I saw
her once a week but for the rest of the
week I was constantly working by myself
I do remember that when I was 13 and
that's the moment where I met I met her
she I found myself I went to a book
bookstore and I wanted to buy I get my
attention just fell on a big a big book
which is Stephen King's it you know it's
an enormous book and I just said I just
planted it and I said I want that one
and the the owner said to my mother it's
not good for him because it's too big
it's too difficult and I think in life
you yeah it's important not to let
anybody tell you what you have to do if
you want to do something you go for it
you go for it and then you'll see
whether he can do it or not and then
what I did is that I insisted and I did
well to insist because I
the book was incredibly good and
incredibly interesting some people might
not like Stephen King bit commercial but
I found that the book incredible and I
highlight a lot of words that I didn't
know obviously was a little it was not
um you know I smooth reading because I
kept coming across words that I didn't
know or expressions etc but it was a
breakthrough as far as my English is
concerned and I also wanted to tell you
that um you know when people ask me for
example why did you learn American
English it's not it's not that I chose
American English it's American English
it chose me because my American tutor my
tutor was America because the movies I
watched were all in American English
because the the books were in an
American English are the expressions of
the culture and because my friends were
Americans I have two dear friends um
Rachel and Garrett hi here's watching
the video and I do remember that you
know I've never I've never been to
America before never I've never been
here outside of European borders I don't
even have a password so shame but I do
remember that America was all around me
was around me all the time and I think
that in order to speak a language fluent
like you don't necessarily need to go to
the country now you might tell yourself
well if I live in a small village in
Australia or in Alaska yeah it's true
it's true that it's not the same thing
as being in a big big cities such as I
like Rome but the thing is that with the
internet you can actually surround
yourself with language you can talk to
people you can watch movies etc so I
think that attitude is what counts the
most
and another thing which is the final
point of this video is that I didn't
deliberately learn how to speak like an
American or have a fartist American
accent I I just enjoyed what I wanted to
what I was doing
I enjoy it greatly and I kept doing that
without asking myself do I speak like
perfectly or not you
the point and the objective languages
are tools for communication when you use
a language you always use words and in
order to convey a message that's that's
the most important thing when people
think and talk about perfection your
your accent is perfect I would like to
have such a perfect accent it's not true
than my accent is perfect I know that a
native English speaker can tell if they
talk to me for a long time but in
channel they can tell that I'm not a
foreigner it doesn't matter the thing is
that the most important thing is the
clarity of your speech both how well you
convey a message and how clearly you
pronounce words if you pronounce words
clearly and you speak well it doesn't
matter if you have an accent really
doesn't and so just the message here is
just enjoy what you are doing if you
choose a language if you like if you
have a connection with that language if
you like what you're doing you are going
to be successful no matter what happens
thank you very much